finally the hey world leader agrees to
talk yes miss villainous jungle MA
Nicholas then meet my staff needs laser
let me out man this is speaking on ya of
everyone is there yeah I'm a pastor I'm
a leader I'm a Christian I'm a father
but this belief is part of my life yeah
and I can't just yeah take it out as
part of me how can I extract knowledge I
cycle through lo de la mano Marrakech
Angolan people admit themselves and say
we have single mother [ __ ] fish yeah
they admit to having it heart escapes me
why they would do that but so people do
confess and sometimes they'll say it
wasn't me it was the ones from over
there or you have them over there yeah
but they'll tell us and we have no idea
so we just believe it is a good sangoma
and bad friend goomer sound oh my god
good Latini anonymous a Samantha Elauf
body for man one is a good good thinking
no not available I'm insensitive the
other one is dangerous yeah Oh mind
accompanies his Monda one of our accused
oh I know warming from her mother was
murdered
she's accused her son is accused so
they're all within the same family
he believes that she has this angleman
spirit inside her I mean believe me most
and I'm not a good guy so he said how
would we know if she has single month
hmm it's a skirt you can't see a spirit
right we've been told a lot of people
who would know because they're also
single mom
Monda has it no we believe it yes we do
know me like it even man asking a killer
but then she said she didn't have it
wrong her rock and the others turned
around and said no it was her Iran so
that first time will get me for the most
bi glow so I asked him in your own life
your wife was accused of being a Tongo
button murdered now do you think she was
murdered he's walking upright so do you
think that she was correctly accused
I'll probably play kill enemy and
through name PJ he's got no family Romy
there's no way than my wife is son
Goomba well I don't accept all right her
family my family and I myself and I
believe she was not singular and it was
completely horrified accusation oh I
know it's all Kolkata but they killed
her anyway but when there's a bad Changu
mom
the people believe it is okay to then
kill them it's do it you have to kill
them it's okay to kill them the right
thing to do
we must get him man we must get him them
this man is priest his own wife was
falsely accused still believes that
witches must be punished in so many ways
this tells me how deep and intractable
the belief in sangoma is here
[Music]